welcome to CBS this morning I'm Gayle
King with Tony jacoco and Anthony Mason
we begin with this story from
Philadelphia where a night long standoff
that paralyzed a Philadelphia
neighborhood is over after the man
accused of wounding six police officers
and shooting repeatedly at others
surrendered overnight his name Maurice
Hill 36 years old he walked out of his
home where he had barricaded himself
holding his hands in the air police say
Hill opened fire when officers came to
the house with a warrant two officers
and three hostages were trapped inside
for about five hours until a SWAT team
rescued them CTM national correspondent
Jericka Duncan is at the scene in
Philadelphia
Jericka what do we know about the
accused gunman we know that the accused
gunman has a criminal history an
extensive criminal history that includes
several gun possession charges now as
for those six officers that were wounded
they were released from the hospital
and are said to be in good spirits this
morning you know you take a look at the
scene behind me right now police still
gathering evidence it is quiet it is
calm but hours ago neighbors here
described it as a war zone rounds of
gunfire terrorized this neighborhood in
Philadelphia for hours officers serving
a narcotics warrant at a home around
4:30 p.m. yesterday were ambushed by
gunmen barricading himself inside the
shooter by multiple rounds officers
returned fire many of whom who had to
escape through windows and doors to get
from a barrage of bullets six officers
were shot including one who was grazed
by a bullet in the head one of the cops
was running past he can hear hair blood
all on his hear heavily armed police
officers dozens of squad cars and SWAT
teams swarmed the area
Oh SWAT police along with the shooters
lawyer were trying to communicate with
the suspect for hours
urging him to surrender and free
hostages SWAT was able to successfully
extract the two police officers that
were trapped upstairs as well as three
prisoners but as darkness began to fall
the thieves didn't let up no more than
seven hours later the gunmen surrendered
with the help of his lawyer Shaka
Johnson I've never known him to possess
the traits that would have a person
shooting at police officers or having a
whole community under siege the six
officers wounded left the hospital as
their fellow officers lined up to salute
them
Philadelphia's mayor used the standoff
to call for gun control whether it's our
six officers who were shot or it's some
15 17 20 year-old kid on the streets of
Philadelphia we get shot with guns that
shouldn't be in people's hands and it's
it's aggravating it's saddening more
than 30 officers discharged their
weapons during this shootout the alleged
gunman was taken to Temple University
Hospital where he was treated for tear
gas exposure he's expected to be
arraigned facing multiple charges that
include six counts of attempted murder
Anthony I'm so glad those six officers
are all okay Jericka you lived in Philly
for three years how's the city reacting
today you know North Philadelphia is an
area that is plagued by gun violence but
naturally people in this area are not
used to seeing hundreds of officers and
crouched down just as nervous as many of
the residents here because they weren't
they didn't know what to expect and then
when you look at the fact that six
officers as you just stated were not
severely injured they went home last
night to their families it is a miracle
as the police commissioner said it is a
blessing jurika thank you very much